[Music]
right in a bit when it's live
you'll see this um cx not live will go
to live i think
it'll start going live in the next
minute or so
i
that's all right we're getting um i've
got nigel barkling waiting room but i
won't
unless you want him in now i'll uh leave
him sat there for a while
waiting for damon right uh it's just
been talking to him he's on his way
oh isn't he he's looking is he actually
coming into the room or was he um
um
so
[Music]
explain what cx live means on the screen
sorry
i believe you have some words to say
about the
comment cx live on the screen at the
moment
oh yes and today we are being streamed
um live to youtube so
and this public is a this sorry this um
meeting is a public meeting
chair just to make members of the board
aware
thank you and we move on to the agendas
there's quite a
busy agenda today a lot of information
coming your way so
let's make a start so if we first of all
go to colleges
of absence again david i'd like to come
to you if you just
listen we have missing today yeah i've
received apologies from
angela stansfield chair okay thank you
very much
uh moving straight on to declarations of
interest
so i'd like to ask if any of the members
have any interest to declare
which are relating to today's agenda
topics
if everyone's shaking ahead and staying
muted then i will take that as a no
and we can continue to point number
three minutes of last meetings
so you've got a few minutes to to attend
to here so i'd like to
ask the the board if everyone agrees
that the minutes from the previous
meetings are a true reflection of those
meetings
uh dating from the fifth of june from
the board meeting and also the informal
meetings held on the 26th of june 10th
of july
and 24th of july thank you chair
to move those it's a true record
thank you very much i'm moving straight
on to
all right can we just get members to
turn the cameras on so we can just get a
show of hands to approve them please
yes it comes
okay thank you you're welcome thank you
and moving on to point four stage two
consultation outcomes
i'll hand you over to carl apps
and next i believe we'll be supporting
this carl
um thank you chair yeah nexus um
i haven't yet joined unfortunately but
i've just spoken to them they're on
their way
and so as you aware we carried out two
consultation events
and the first one was regarding um
people's perceptions of clay cross as it
is now
so it was uh those people who live and
work in clay cross but also who
go to school there or who visit for
whatever reason
so that was to understand the baseline
in terms of what it is that they think
works well and what is it that they
think
potentially could be improved within
clay cross
those ideas were taken alongside the
vision
that the board had already um started to
work together and
to see um where the whether that sort of
lies in terms of what we can do
to um enhance the the offering within
clay cross
uh and then peter and his team started
to develop the ideas
based on the feedback that it originally
had and the original
vision of the board looked at the built
environment
start to look at the evidence base as
well from local plan
and other um such pieces of work that
have been done
to understand um what sort of level of
intervention is required within clay
cross
the projects were identified as as the
board has seen and
spoken to spoken about previously and
then these were
taken out to be consulted to the um
the wider group play cross the
part of the consultation was to send a
postcard to fa address now
i understand the first consultation
there was issues not every address
received those so we tried to make sure
within our second consultation that
those
were received we also created
questionnaires that were
on the website and there was paper
copies uh within shops within
the district where people were able to
website within playgrounds where people
were able to um to fill out that paper
copy and then post
there and then all that was analyzed by
peter and his team
and peter did you want to talk a bit
more about um
the work that's happened post that so
what i've done in a minute is just
explained the process for
the consultation for phase one process
uh
phase two and what was um
uh consulted upon
and you're on me by the way oh just
sorry for being like technical issues um
yeah happy to do that carl is that is
that specifically in relation to the
consultation or more broadly in terms of
the strategy overall
initially talking about the consultation
so it's just to give a abroad i gave a
broad outline as to
how and why um yeah
well no not really as as carl said we we
given
structures we sought to try and um
engage as many people as we could and
leaflets were distributed to all
properties
uh summary boards were placed in a
number of
shops including tesco's
as well as a number of shops on on
market street
and those were signposted that so people
were aware that
there was opportunities to look at those
on on in
hard copy so to speak in the shops um
and obviously there was a number of uh
social media
posts through the course of the
consultation again to
encourage people to respond
so obviously we've uh we've analyzed uh
the outcome of
that consultation and i'm just trying to
find my copy of that but overall
as you can see the
for those that responded and i think we
would have liked more to respond but
i think my senses and i
might be wrong here that people felt
they've kind of already given us
their to-do list if you like in the
first stage and that's certainly
something that we have
used to develop the framework but
overall there is
uh for those that responded there is
strong support
for the vision
for the strategy so that that should
give us some
some confidence and that was certainly
i don't think hell's mentioned as yet
the feedback from the town's hub
to date has been very uh supportive and
complementary around the consultation
that's been
undertaken so that is something that we
can
major on in the presentation of the tip
i suppose at that point there's um if
there's any questions on the
consultation
and so now's the time to feel them i
suppose
that's open to the room any questions
if not then i say thank you and we move
on to
point five which is the the draft tip
again that's back to
carl okay so um peter's going to be
talking you through the draft tip in a
moment but
what i i'd ask you to have in mind is
uh reading the tip if you were to take
out the name clay cross
do you think it would adequately
describe clay cross as a place
so is it taking away that any town any
place type factor so is it rooted in the
place
and the individual challenges that clay
cross has
do do you think is that that's
adequately and displayed in the tip
and also do you think the the projects
and
the things that we've identified within
the tip do you think that's
resolves the issues that have been
raised and also does it feed into the
vision
that you as a board have created so
once peter's talked you through the tip
if you could have that in mind
i'm presuming you've read the tip
already and you you sort of understand
the themes if you can think of those
things i think does it answer those
questions i think that's quite important
in terms of
when we put the tip in um if we've
ticked those boxes
so peter if you want to talk us further
too
yes again i'm in technical difficulties
can't seem to load any documents this
morning
is it worth the tip being square shared
on the screen that would be
fabulous if something if you could do
that
are you able to do that or joe
great correct yeah excellent thank you
very much um
so this this is uh there's two elements
to the
to the tip to the town investment one
submission
that we need to to submit at the end of
october
this is the first part which is is the
overarching
strategy if you like and in many ways
the key document at this stage the the
second part of the tip
is the effectively the projects
um and more detail on those projects
which we are
working up and i think we are due to
issue
probably a draft there's a motherboard i
think in a
couple of weeks so we will be issuing a
draft of that document
um ahead of that meeting but i think
subject to the agenda i think it'd be
useful
to run through the projects and
kind of outline where we are at at the
moment
we're coming back to this document if if
we
scroll through fairly quickly again
nicole i don't know whether you've
mentioned that we've this this has been
presented to the towns of the
project coordinators for
government sorry carl sorry no not yet
and i was going to pick that up later on
and right feedback from that okay fine
um so so this has been issued to to the
township and
kind of respond on the feedback on that
so obviously
we set the context uh we i think
importantly if you could just scroll up
that
page um we identify
the vision which is as we said we have
consulted on we then identify
in headline terms the projects so
obviously market street clay cross
creative
bridge street the skills hub public
realm
charlie park and the leisure center the
potential for a rail station
low carbon workspace at coney green and
the district heating pilot
so we we prevent present the overall
strategy
and if we scroll onto the next page
we begin to kind of set clay cross in
its context
and important to the township and
government is is that we are
we are understanding of the context and
then we are relating into
wider sub-regional and regional
strategies so again
that's an important aspect of this uh
presentation to to the town's fund
scroll on a little more
obviously that's the area that we are
dealing with which you'll be familiar
with
keep going
so again here what we do is we we
identify the key issues the key
challenges
that um the town's fund
project is intended to address
so a lack of vibrancy and
quality in the town centre and that's
certainly something that has been picked
up through
consultation and remains very important
to the local community
aligned to that is his image and
perception
i think both within the community but
also externally
in terms of the investment proposition
of clay cross
there's issues of you know poor
connectivity and i think we
want to continue to kind of build on
this this case but
there is you know clearly the
opportunity around the rail station
which would significantly improve
connectivity of the town
to the region but also issues of
of um disconnect and severance
particularly around the
with high street and the scale of
traffic on that so again that's an
important aspect for us
jobs and skills and education again a
key aspect of what we're
looking to do and that forms the
platform for the
student things that the skills hub
there is an issue as we all know around
health and well-being and there is
clearly
the um
the leisure center and related green
infrastructure opportunities respond to
that
we then kind of run through the evidence
of
need that we've put together which i
think you you've
had sight of previously in terms of the
baseline
material that we've put together so a
lot of this will be
familiar with to you so i don't propose
to go through that
again at this point unless people want
to but clearly you know
it's a it's a challenging property
market
uh there are issues around traffic
management and road safety and as i've
said before
severance so that's what we refer to in
terms of connectivity
we've also referenced obviously the
digital connectivity and
whilst um
the the infrastructure is there one of
the challenges is obviously businesses
making use of that and accessing that
connectivity uh there is an issue
as we touched on obviously around low
wages and low
value added jobs that we need to
consider how we can address
keep moving through
so lots of dates have been put together
on on making
socio-economic challenge which i think
is
is has been well demonstrated in
clay cross
and again opportunities to to improve
health
just quality of life issues
keep flying through this because i'd say
it's all context which you'll be very
familiar with if we stop
there just for a second um as carl's
mentioned one of the things key things
that um
the towns fund are keen to see
is that this is
the strategy is is set in its place it
reflects the character of clay cross and
that's an important aspect for them
and this feeds into how we should and
could present the town's assets and
strengths the distinctive character of
the town so as it stands that you know
we are identifying heritage and
landscape and
shouldn't underestimate the kind of
resonance of the
george stevenson's connection because
you know ultimately part of this
is about presentation and
peaking people's interest reference to
those
kind of issues certainly does that
we will talk about strong manufacturing
base the fact that there is
a relatively kind of
vibrant small business community
although obviously needs support
um uh there's a strong community we've
talked to
talked about accessibility we need to
develop our
view of digital connectivity and how
that's fast again
in place uh needs to need to be better
access by
businesses in terms of the key
opportunities that we're
right identifying we've got a later
version but we are
identifying uh that we're working on the
moment
but i think the the key opportunities
are i suppose mirror images of some of
the challenges
there is an opportunity to kind of bring
about a radical improvement
of the town centre uh there is
uh you know there is significant public
ownership within the town centre
uh the whilst some areas are in private
ownership there aren't a huge amount of
private sector ownerships in the
key parts that we are looking at so
there is a real opportunity there to
make some significant change it's
clearly an opportunity to build on the
heritage of
the town there's an opportunity around
the the relatively compact
nature of the town so there is an
opportunity to
ensure that all facilities are within
ready walking and cycling distance of
the community we have the key assets of
charlie park and kenny park as we talked
about before
again that that could come out in a
strand of quality of life of active
active movement to travel and so forth
um there is a as we touched on a history
to the town
we need to major on that and
underline the distinctive character of
the town uh and there is it would seem
to be kind of an emerging opportunity
around art and
creative making so some of those
elements
will need to come through strongly
next section so
again a lot of this will be familiar
with to you so don't
propose to go through in detail so we
have the vision
we have the key strands that vision
uh we need to do some some further work
on
defining uh our outcomes and that this
you know this may well be a topic for
discussion
effectively what are we aiming to do
what are
going to be our event benchmark
returns on this investment
in terms of objectives
the strategy as
as you'll be familiar with hopefully
kind of aligns around a series of
themes of things objectives so it's
it town century generation is a key part
of that and that is in part as we've
talked about before kind of focusing a
lot of the
investment activity new development in
and around the town centre and then
connecting the rest of the
town and the key assets into that so
that we're creating a
focal point to the town and we're
creating that that sense of activity and
pacific pride and then obviously flowing
onto that we we go into
things like connectivity which is
important we need to ensure that
the community has access to the
opportunities both within the town
and elsewhere skills and enterprise is
important we need to raise
skills levels educational attainment
and aspiration so that is a very
important kind of central aspect to what
we're doing
uh health and well-being kind of
underpins the
whole strategy and and it's important
that we tie the likes of the shelley
park leisure center the green
infrastructure the active travel
elements of this
into a kind of wider strategy
and clean growth is is an important
aspect of that and that for us is
is the potential approach around
district heating pilot and low carbon
energy strategy and and probably
mentioned shortly the town subsidy that
is
potentially quite very important in
terms of the presentation of our bid
there's a unique or fairly unique aspect
of transformation as far as i've seen
today
the next bit is around uh you know
strategic alignment
so this is all about and we can skip
through this really quickly it's saying
that
all this the strategy is really embedded
and reflects
national regional local policy and
you know it does it's very strong in in
that respect so there's a clear line
between national policy regional policy
in what way
we are endeavoring to do
you talk then about the spatial strategy
which again will be familiar to you
concentration on regeneration in the
town centre and then connecting
key assets and communities into that so
that's been a fairly consistent part of
this is
all the way through and you'll be
familiar with the
trust diagram that encapsulates
the vision and strategy
these are again it's important
and we've probably got a little bit of
work to do on this but it's important
from the townsfolk point of view that we
have a clear
covered recovery
strategy that is reflected in this
approach and obviously that is in
significant element of that is you know
a regeneration of
the town center and the creation of
people-friendly western environments and
so forth
there's also obviously the green
recovering and the net zero carbon
agenda which is very important
and as we touched on before promoting
aspiration and promoting growth
so then then we have to go through a
process
of outlining how we have arrived at the
projects that we
uh have identified as you recall
england just going back to your um
contribution to local and national
strategic power
what you're missing there is northeast
derbyshire built facilities and physical
activity strategies within that
okay
sorry to interrupt that's okay well if
you drop me
drop me a line on that
chat box yeah and obviously but you know
there's a wealth of uh policy and
strategy so um
i'll just missed anything but yeah
please
feel free to to add any in there um
so we we as you recall we've been
through a process of
of identifying how these projects
fit within our strategy
and we have
through discussion and and reference to
the
the following principles we've we've
developed the framework in terms of
identifying the priorities and that's
that you know we continue to have that
discussion as we get towards the kind of
sharp end of the
of the the bidding process
and if we then click on
we then have to present the what's
called the logic
model which is is essentially kind of
the relationship between context
and issues with projects and outcomes
the outcomes then obviously are intended
to
address the issues so hopefully what we
ultimately have there is a
virtuous circle so it's taken us from
the issues to what our response is to
what the outcomes
will be click
on so then we uh
we go through the projects as they stand
um and as i said before this is
essentially a kind of
summary of uh
tip two that we need to develop and
maybe
we we kind of leave this and perhaps
come back to a discussion on that
if we have time that's appropriate but
again
these projects will you will be very
familiar with
um we consistently
run through the strategy what we
are aiming to do is um
i think we have done at this point is
kind of identify a tip ask
of 25 million pounds
because that's the kind of the order of
moneys that we
feel that we can justify though there is
um you know
upwards up to 50 million available but
the advice
is that that is for kind of you know
nationally unique
projects um not that we
don't necessarily have those at the
moment but i think we're
probably thinking that the 25 million
particularly given that the
couple of the key projects such as
district heating and the energy network
of
energy network and the rails
ticket against them
we can only really present those as
feasibility studies at this
stage peter and lee hickens got a
question
he wants to surprise
thank you carl thank you chair uh so to
interrupt peter
just a couple of uh questions really
uh comments as well if i called at this
stage
on the page 100 i think uh council
northeast obviously council plan needs
to be added
uh as well as uh but that's just a minor
point i'll put all these in
writing here i just wonder whether we
whether we're making enough
about the what we know already in terms
of the
economic impact that
uh physical activities sport and
healthy communities uh
help to generate so there's plenty of
information out there and
don't put andy on the spot but i know
there's a sport england document that
um suggests 3.3 3.91 for every pound
spent in a community is generated back
in terms of economic
and economic uh benefit
well i suppose it's a question i'm not
sure we're going to get an answer
today but the group will probably know
that we've been working in the
background on
uh on our strategic
delivery plan for facilities which is
what uh
andy james has just mentioned there and
i just wonder at what
point do we do the board decide
on some of the detail because i know we
mentioned charlie park
quite often uh but there's a distinct
difference
between a replacement leisure facility
and an iconic community
hub which is the work that we were
working on
and i think at some point we need to
determine
what the direction is and i understand
you know there's there's many things to
try and satisfy
through this process and trying to
strike a balance
across the town but there's a there's a
real difference in deliverability
of those two if we don't nail
what we want down at this stage uh not
least in terms of cost
so i'm just wondering when we decide
whether we're going
for a community hub style
facility that has been worked upon in
the background for
18 months or we're going through a
replacement leisure center as part of
this bid
that's all thanks before so chad before
the board answers that
question just want to go back to lee's
first point
um part of the town hub and response
i was going to come to later was around
some of the policy
sort of um supporting evidence and
if leaf or and andy from sport england
if you could send us that information
that can be part of the evidence base
that um
we're not lacking but what they said was
it it would be stronger if we could
point to more sources of evidence based
so
leo and if you could send that to me
that'd be really helpful sorry jay if
you
the board wants to discuss the leisure
center
yeah so it'd be good to hear comments
from the group
i think uh it's andy from sporting and i
think lee's right
i think um he's been a bit uh
liberal with his destination of 18
months we've been working on the charlie
park development in the wider
environments for probably three or four
years now
certainly in terms of possibilities for
accessing sport england funding we
wouldn't want
it to be just a leisure centre
what our funding really buys is that
community focus
community hub model so whereby you would
have a
ledger center building alongside that or
co-located
is is other services and that's
certainly what we've uh
what we've been working on we have got
um strategic outcome planning guidance
document that's
i think correct me if i'm wrong clearly
very near near completion
so carl that's got lots and lots of
evidence for you in terms of some of the
things that you were talking about
so i think um it's up to lee whether he
wants to send you a draft of that
but that's certainly what we've been
working on uh most recently to provide
that evidence base
thanks chad
yeah i think you've got i'm not sure if
you're able to see but in the chat bar
you've got council jeremy kenyon and
myself who are uh
wanting to come in yeah i think
okay bye gary are you next thank you um
yeah it's a really good document uh i'd
pick up on what lee
just said about the leisure center uh
six million pounds and a
vanilla leisure center is not really
what we had in mind and i think it
probably needs to be bigger and
have a larger summer allocated to it as
a community
facility um just very minor one first on
the detail in 4.4.4 you've got probably
the only typo in the document
it says it can form meeting the needs of
the community
and it'd be good to have the total ask
for doing that i think it's just over 24
million at the moment isn't
it but the main thing is going back to
something carl asked at the beginning
about does it describe clay cross
uh i i think it's missing a couple of
things um
first thing is it's a key town for a lot
more than just the 8 000 residents that
the tip seems to be about and you know
you could have a town of 8 000 with
nobody nearby
and that's a very different thing for
someone evaluating the bid
compared to the clay cross situation
which is
it's the town for i know 20 000 or so
uh people and i think that needs to be
really brought out in the background
information maybe with a map showing how
close the nearby
population clusters are exactly one
thing
and the other thing in terms of the
context is it's very polite shall we say
and very positive
and the negative information is in there
in tables and it's dry
and also the vision's a bit sort of
motherhood and honey sort of thing it's
got all good things
um and i think that that that would be a
bit more direct
um for example you could summarize the
vision as
make clay cross a place everyone wants
to visit move to and stay
sort of more pithy summary of the vision
not to replace the vision but just to
tag it and then the other thing i'd say
is we should make more of the
in the background and the jobs and
skills that that the lack of
desirability of clay cross is a big
influence on
young and working age people and leads
them moving away for
better life opportunities and that
creates a bit of a negative cycle
and that locks clay cross into staying
behind the national averages i think
those
those points well i don't know what
people think but for me those are the
things that should be added into the
context areas
peter did you want to respond to those
points
yeah contributions welcome i think yeah
i think it's a valid point around
uh you know the wider context and the
clay cross has a wider role
and regeneration of clay cross would
have uh
significant benefits um
yeah again you know skills and
aspiration is an important part of this
and we need to make sure that comes out
around the vision i suppose we you know
we have consulted on the vision
and people signed up to that but i
suspect what we could do is kind of
say well that's the vision but you know
this is what it means
on your point you know in simple terms
it means
it means this so we can add that in uh
the other challenge that i should should
mention is is that there's
uh believe it or not there's word limits
on everything
so we're only allowed i think it's ten
thousand words and we're at that already
so
something you might take something out
but we can't we can make use
of um of uh
indices and so forth and and maps as has
been mentioned
um i think the thing on funding and and
money's attributed it's just useful to
bear in mind and you're probably aware
of this but the funding that we put
against those is the ask
from tip it's not the
total cost of any given project
necessarily
and that certainly would apply in our
minds in terms of the
uh of the leisure center
so we we would see currently seeing that
as as absolutely and others are
leading on that but we see that the cost
of that being
more than that so the other discussion
that we're going to have to have is
about co-funding and other sources of
funding
for these projects yeah thank you peter
and we have a question from
councillor dale yeah thank you jeff um
i suppose i would echo some of the
comments already made by lee hicken and
and jeremy i think i agree with with
most of those
um i suppose there's a couple of points
from me
uh first one is that um i've had a few
conversations with
uh together with lee rowley uh
presidents in
uh in the clay cross area
and quite a few of them um have
talked about uh and which is referenced
in the plan which is a good thing talked
about a lot of the
um kind of walking cycling
infrastructure
uh within the community to connect the
different parts of the town
but also to connect the the town to the
fantastic countryside that's around it
and i
i got the sense from the document that
there's a lot of
references to that but it doesn't and
forgive me if i'm missing it but it
doesn't feel like there's any sort of
specific
uh sort of references to to projects
that we would like to pursue
uh with regard to that so it's it's it's
there in the plan but it's not really
kind of concrete and
and pointing at a sense of you know this
this project here would
uh would would link these two uh
pathways or you know
and and actually link out into the
countryside and do all of that side of
it so that's that's kind of one point
and then the other point is a bit around
what peter said
uh in terms of how sort of ambitious we
should be i appreciate obviously we
we we sort of held back a bit to an
extent by the fact that we aren't
able to um in terms of the two
so the most innovative aspects of this
uh
with the district heating and the rail
station we're kind of held back by the
fact that
these projects are at a very early stage
and therefore
um uh you know feasibility is all we're
really looking at
um i i just wondered if you could talk a
bit more about
about uh about how ambitious we can be
and what the sort of criteria is in
terms of
um what government are saying on that
because i'm sort of aware that
we could have up to fifty thousand fifty
million uh for grabs but
um you're sort of suggesting that that's
only going to be kind of one or two
um or a small number of town deals that
are able to achieve that and i just
wondered if you could talk to us a bit
more about what the
um what the kind of what you really need
to show in order to have that sort of a
bit
because i think from my perspective i'd
like us to be as ambitious as we
possibly can and i wonder whether
are we throwing away a chance um by not
you know are we are we are we losing
anything by being a bit more bold and
ambitious
even if we don't get that sort of level
of funding um
or are we better being a bit more
cautious in what we approach government
for because
they might view it dimly if if if we're
over egging ourselves if you see what i
mean
that's sort of a question really i
suppose so thanks
okay thank you and i think we've got a
question from councillor renwick
thank you chair um yeah i just want to
say starters and
it's a really good start for 10. um i
think we've
picked up all the key points that were i
think that all of us are individually
interested in
and and collectively um and i suppose
really
um i'm agreeing a little bit with the
councillor dale um
there's so i think sometimes a bit of a
lack of a bit more specific detail so
i'm interested a little bit more about
about the upskilling how we're going to
do that i think if we had a little bit
more
specifics to try and um
demonstrate that we're with that little
bit maybe further forward and i know
it's got time constraints but
the demonstrated project skills health
and well-being and can get understand
the health and well-being
and leisure but not from the from a from
a wider
health perspective i just wonder looking
at all the other
ones that have gone in and what do you
think our uniqueness
is is is it something that can be this
together as a
uniqueness to makes it look different
from every other bid out there that will
be asking for the same things
what's pulling it together is it one
unique differentiation for clay cross
i think maybe it's worth going back to
peter to ask us answer a couple of those
questions
so firstly to the the 50 million then
the
green area link and then obviously the
uni unique usp
um
yeah you know the 50 million is is a
valid question i haven't got the
terminology in front of me but i think i
think it's
you know it's something along the lines
of
nationally outstanding or nationally
unique
groundbreaking you know so it has to be
something that is
particularly special uh i think we have
we also have to bear in mind
that we are in
town investment fund contest we are it's
a relatively small
community it's a relatively small town
you know
the towns such as i think
blackpool for example in worcester
they're in this process you know which
are sizeable means to say that
the 50 million would also come obviously
with outputs
and commensurate increasing outputs and
and
you know as it stands that you know it's
a useful challenge and
we'll think about that again and a lot
we'll have that conversation with
the towns pub but i
i wouldn't underestimate well you've
made the point
valid valid point that there's two very
ambitious projects in there that are in
a
relatively small ticket costs at the
moment
you know the railway station and the
district heating
project are you know very ambitious
projects in themselves
which uh will require you know
significant amounts of funding that go
beyond this
strategy so you know overall strategy is
you know he's getting on for 50 million
i would have thought
um tom could come in to assist on this
answer as well peter
i think yeah coming from tom there
sorry just finding my own move button um
no i i was just coming in
basically on that so the 50 million that
we've been guided
is few and far between i think is the
balance from government that we're
getting and the
initial impression that we're getting
from them is that like peter said
it's going to be exceptional
circumstances and where there's real
sort of game changers so i would focus
on a good
sort of 25 million pound bid if you can
all leading up towards that
i mean following on and just got to a
few of the points before me but
what you have to take into account when
you bid in for this funding is that
you've got to go with the benefit cost
ratio against all of
these projects and value for money
scoring
um so it's bid for 50 million pounds and
score highly on a benefit cost ratio
you're going to have to really give some
weight in terms of the outputs that
they'll deliver
um and then the other piece for me
really is finding match funding that can
complement that
and co-funding for these projects so if
you're going to put 50 million pounds
worth of bids in uh you're going to have
to find some serious weight from private
sector investors
and other public sector investors to
make sure that you have
sort of that tangible match funding to
put against these projects
i think they will be really a couple and
not very many nationwide
sorry jeff i can melanie's put a comment
in
the comment box i'll read out just
because um for the benefit they're
recording i'm
sorry do you want me to carl i'm quite
happy to sort of say it
thanks yeah i just want to articulate
what what you know what tom said he's
is he beat me to it um but yes
the the tips of over 25 million so
whether that's
just over 25 million or up to 50 million
will
will be the exception and and we'll need
to demonstrate that regional national
significance but also just i think
important for you to sort of remember in
terms of your ambitions around the rail
station
is the importance of the time scale for
delivery and
and and you know the likelihood of that
actually coming to fruition within the
time frame of town's fund
is is highly unlikely isn't it so
looking at it in terms of feasibility
and where you may get to in the future
is probably the best course of action
for the for the take the train station
particularly
okay thank you maybe if you can go back
to peter now for the question on
the green areas yeah but i think that
point kind of applies
to a number of projects really is what
what
what we're doing here is establishing
the headlines you know
we haven't the
working out the detail and developing
the detail will be for the
business planning phase which will kick
off you know
in in the autumn um so
whilst we've got you know an idea of the
opportunities and
and the issues to be addressed what what
needs to be done as a
as a next stage or you know
some of that work can be developed now
but that's subject to kind of
a decision but as as it stands what what
we need to do is just kind of identify
the headline
opportunities and uh describe kind of
broad order
costs or budgets to those and then it
will be
in terms of developing further detail
for the green infrastructure the
skillshare
and so forth it will be a case of
developing the
uh the business plan in terms of um
uniqueness i think i think there's two
elements to my mind
that we can present as unique
and perhaps they're related i think it
comes back to them to the kind of
relatively compact and defined nature of
play cross and the fact that we are
looking at uh
what the townsfolk have already
identified as a unique kind of energy
strategy
so i think it's around about genuinely
trying to take
clay cross on a journey towards you know
zero carbon
and all the benefits of that in terms of
sustainability and so forth and
potentially what we could also be
looking at and we've made
contact with the midlands energy hub
around this is zero carbon bench market
so i think i think the uniqueness is
that you can through what through this
work and other work in terms of the town
center
skills energy accessibility and so forth
you can actually
present clay cross as a opportunity
to show how sustainable growth and
development can actually happen
and and that you can be you know a
demonstrator for
smaller towns across the country as to
how this could work so i think that's
the
in some ways that's the kind of what i
would suggest is kind of the unique
thread to this potential
okay now if we move on to the the
upscaling topic i think richard you want
to come in on this
uh yeah hi um uh richard morgan from
chesterfield college because i've not
not met everyone on the call i don't
think
um yeah it's just looking at the the the
skills hub and
three million pounds to do that i'm just
not clear
what that's going to do and just to give
some context if we
were bidding as a college uh separately
for for three million pounds
we'd be probably looking at about a
thousand job outcomes uh to justify
um our bid and then how we leverage
other funding which i'm sure will sort
of adult education funding for
upskilling uh unemployed and
underemployed people
and apprenticeship um uh funding to get
people into jobs and help them move on
with their career
um and it just seems a bit thin the
justification there
there aren't really any job outcomes um
we're talking about
um having it as a hub for worcester
bosch which is great to have a
an industry partner and sponsor but what
jobs are going to come out of it from
them being there you know
what what's their plan to create and
sustain jobs in
the local community um and again what
what you need from us
as an organization and other providers
to to match
um funding with uh for us to commit
funding to this from from other funding
pots we've got i'm just not i'm just not
clear what what we're doing with that
three million quid what the outcomes are
going to be
and what part us and other providers
need to
play in that
peter would like to respond to that
yeah well i suppose again similar point
applies really you know
we've um hopefully you know we've come a
long way since
since june in terms of you know the
overall shape of the bid
and you know there's certainly been lots
of discussions around
skills and skills and so forth
uh we
can we can do we can only do so much
within the kind of time available
to kind of develop the the detail of
any or all of these projects uh there's
clearly further discussions to be had
and we'll be having them with with
richard and others around
kind of uh outline commitments and
outline costs and so forth but
fundamentally what we're doing at this
point is identifying the kind of
headline
uh opportunities and headline
projects and there will be inevitably
a lot of work that needs to be done
through the business planning phase
to kind of tie that down so in terms of
costs were on that project in particular
i believe we're kind of referencing back
to
the one public estate material because
bear in mind this is predominantly a
kind of capital cost
uh funding request
so again there's a whole a lot of work
to be done alongside the kind of revenue
side of things but in the meantime if we
you know if richard and others have
information that we can
draw on um we will be having a further
meeting of
the skills training group anyway to kind
of go through that detail
on tip two then um please send it
through but in
in the meantime we'll wait to have that
meeting and talk this through in detail
obviously peter we've got employers like
mr bosh where i'm currently working
we're looking at a change in um
market segment in the coming years
really as the the oil market declines
we have to move towards newer
technologies which will need of scaling
for
some of the local people as well so long
term it could have an influence in the
local
businesses so something that
play across for worcester bosch would be
very interested in
okay then we move on to andrew king i
think you had a question
uh yes yeah this was really
a comment on the um the page 94
2.4 the town's assets and strengths
and i thought we could really make
more of uh the strategic location of
clay cross
which uh i mean i think we do like
knowledge that we're on the a61 corridor
we're obviously very close to the m1
corridor uh we've got two uh
main railway lines uh that go
through uh the town uh and
i think i believe in terms of
geographical
uh location in the country we are uh
more or less uh about at the center
and i think that we can make more of
this and i think
you know it does in a way this sort of
follows on from uh councillor kenyon's
point
which is saying yes we're you know we
you know the document
identifies that we're that we're a small
one-horse town if you like less than 10
000 people
uh but as as counselor kenyan says we
are
uh serving uh a vast number of uh
large settlements uh which see clay
cross as the place
uh for them to come to to be serviced
and
by buy goods and and and transact
business and
uh there must be good 20 000 people uh
in the north wingfield wingworth uh
stratton
ashover and other surrounding districts
but also uh this strategic location
uh if we could draw attention to how we
fit
into uh the uh you know the country on
a national basis i think that that might
resonate well
uh with the persons who are going to
appraise
this this submission so that's my
observation
thank you thank you any feedback on that
peter
i'll take that as an offer now okay i
think uh andy you had your hand up
earlier is that correct
i'm not sure if i've missed you out just
let me make myself
i'm still getting used to that after all
this time working at home
um yeah it was just um uh the counsellor
earlier on
mentioned about connectivity between
sites connectivity in terms of
of of green networks and that's
something i've mentioned quite a couple
of times
at these at these meetings um uh
sporting and have a document called
active design
um carl i'm just sending you a link to
that i don't know whether you want to
circulate it around the board
yeah well thank you for them to uh to
have a look at but it addresses
um all the things that the council was
talking about earlier on about
you know connecting your schools your
colleges your places of
your places of works and you're looking
at skills creativity
how would you connect those those places
so not just in terms of
you know looking at the focus for
physical activity but also looking at
the community element
also dclg are quite keen on using that
so it might be worth call
somewhere in your document just putting
a flag to that that you'll follow where
you count the principles of that
um might might give us a bit more of a
usp
as council renwick was talking about
okay that's it for me
i hope that was helpful
okay thank you very much uh receive
comments from
councillor kenyon do you want to read
that out just so it's noted on the the
live stream as well
okay yes i'm just uh making the point
that um
for the um energy clean energy
the pass for clay cross was obviously a
lot of coals involved
very dirty energy and the energy from
coal mines which is uh
being explored at the moment is uh it
completes sort of the reformation of
that past into
a clean green future and it's also a
very practical thing so
making more of that i think would be a
good thing
okay i can see thumbs up across the room
sonic that's a
good positive comment uh apologies
warren i think we moved on a little bit
too quickly for you earlier
would you like to comment on the
yeah i put it in in the chat but it's
just
ensuring really that we understand
there's a market failure
locally uh and ensure that the hub is
complementary to the local
provision and doesn't just displace some
numbers so i think you know
testing that a bit better would be good
okay thank you that's good info for
peter there
do we have more questions have i missed
anyone it's been a little bit hectic
trying to keep up with you
it's uh lee rowley it's by mate
yes of course um um i think the document
is really good
as a starter as carolyn council running
said thank you very much for all the
hard work that's been put into it i
think it's
a much better position than it was a few
months ago so thank you um a couple of
points from me one
i think i'd align with the point that
there's probably a
a coherence to it which we need to think
about uh
in the next few weeks how do we bring
everything together into a
into a single thread uh so that there's
a sort of story that can be told and
things can be hung off it i'm not a
marketeer
but it would seem that we need a more of
a coherence to it whether it's
around transport or energy or even
george stevenson you know we could be in
the market for saying we want to create
a square in the center that's named
after george stevenson or whatever
because
but i think there's a coherence point
which we need to have a think about
um i'd really value um the opportunity
just to go through this
in a bit more detail for when the
minister asks me
some stuff coming up so i'd be grateful
for a briefing particularly on the
numbers and things
some of the points that have been raised
so i'll organize that
um separately and just so i'm clear from
a government's perspective this is just
a discussion for
comment rather than a request for
decision at this stage
is that right so i'm clear about the
government around this document
yeah at this point it's just um we're
discussing
the um the draft uh tip just to see is
it going in the right direction
are you comfortable with what's been
suggested
the figures as as we've said need to be
um
looked at because at the minute they are
kind of ballpark figures making sure
they add up to 25 million
we've got a meeting with tom in the
diary for next friday
we'll have a meeting with tom in the
dive next friday to just discuss those
make sure that sure they're tightened up
and um
more accurate and obviously we'll take
on board what's been discussed today
so at this point it's kind of a noted
thing are you comfortable with the
direction of travel for the draft tip
and as it picked up on the key themes as
it uh
suitably identified clay cross as an
area and
we recognize that there's a golden
thread that needs to go through
all the projects and we're thinking
based on the um checking challenge
that's probably around energy
because that is quite important and
although some of the stuff is going to
happen beyond the life of the tip
everything that we do now needs to make
sure that it's working towards
um that sort of low carbon and area for
playgrounds because we feel based on the
feedback is that that is our usp
for clay cross and
coming from my side as well lee carl's
going to give a little bit of an
overview of the next steps so with
regards to the timeline and when we have
to finalize this tip for submission as
well
so maybe that'll make it a little bit
clearer for you as well that helps
thank you
were there any more questions
have i missed anybody who's asked for to
speak at the moment
if not maybe carl do we need to have a
couple of days where people can put any
questions to you in writing which we can
discuss later
um yeah yeah it's a very large document
such a yeah i think that quite useful um
so should we say all questions back by
next friday i mean that gives people
a week um to think about it if they feel
that's um too long then then let me know
but if you have more questions by friday
and then we can sort of hopefully
respond to them
um appropriately and make sure it's all
reflected in the tip
as it goes forward yeah so maybe if you
can put questions in writing to
call direct and you can make sure the
right people get the the questions
okay thank you then if we can move on to
the next point on the agenda
outcomes of the town hub check and
challenge session
so again straight back to you carl thank
you chair
and so we had the the session on uh
monday or tuesday this week i can't
exactly remember which and
um overall it was a very positive
meeting actually they were
um happy with a lot of the the
plan investment plan there was obviously
some things that we need to
start thinking about and how we do it
slightly differently
and part of it is mel who's uh who's
obviously here and the minute has got to
read it and
market and understand it so we need to
make it as easy for mel
as possible and as peter's already said
we're at the word near nearly at the
word limit for ten thousand words
so we need to start thinking about
whether we need to present it in a
slightly different way
and maybe some more graphics um some
more maps
because i think you know a picture
paints a thousand words as
the saying goes and then there's also
some other bits that we
we've kind of meet and discussed as
we've gone through the
the work actually peter mentioned it so
yeah very much needs to be that golden
thread we've identified energy as we
think is um
is something that um sort of fits in
quite well
and it fits in with the board's
aspirations for that long term
and the government aspirations as well
in terms of low carbon
so we're going to look at that in a bit
more detail there's
also um some areas where if we've
we've demonstrated it but the evidence
base could be
a bit clearer i suppose so we're going
to start pulling on some other evidence
base to sort of say to some triangulate
in terms of
well we've said this and it's sort of um
shown here and here as well as uh just
in one area
and also the cobra 19 so we have
um discussed it but we haven't really
put it into a
sufficient detail suppose you know it's
a global pandemic
and so we need to say how is this tip
going to support
the recovery of clay cross and there's
been
a recovery plan for north east
derbyshire and also for the county
council so that's something that
um we can sort of reference and make
sure is included
in that and making better use of
appendices was something that they
sort of raised with us as well so um
some of the
drier and harder to read stats and and
the like
could go into the appendices and and
then be referenced that way and then
that gives us obviously more work out
and
we can improve the the presentation
really i suppose so
overall it was a very uh positive
meeting um
peter mel i don't know if there's
anything that i've missed that you think
he's adding
peter's not in satsang now oh i would
just like to fly the fact that the
town delivery partnership was was
actually very very impressed with the
level of consultation that you've done
and actually that you need to just draw
that out a little more
within the tip so actually sort of blow
your own trumpet on that really
so there we go i'm even underselling our
own consultation
even on the feedback so yeah yeah that's
that's a very good point actually
uh the consultation then it's also
making sure that consultation
um continues as we move through into the
next phase of the the tip
and and hopefully when we get the 25
million from government and start to
deliver that we need to make sure that
that excellent consultation work
continues
so yeah that's the feedback from the
checking challenge session
okay thank you very much and uh if we
move straight on to the
the next point which is the brief
overview of current state's next steps
so again straight back to you carl i'm
afraid okay thank you
and so as as we know the the tip is
due to be um submitted originally it was
very first but
that's a saturday so it's going to be
the 30th of october
uh is the submission date for our tip
we've got
um another um board meeting on the 9th
of october at that point hopefully we'll
be in a position to discuss the final
tip in more detail
it might be that we need to uh convene
another
uh meeting um after that but before the
30th obviously
to just make sure we've absolutely
finalized the tip
and where we are so um i don't know
if everybody's seen the papers there's a
diagram that lifted from the
uh the town hall works so at this point
you submit your time investment plan
obviously we'll do that on the 30th of
october
and then the mhclg or clgu and review
your your plan and offer your heads of
terms uh agreement accordingly
uh workers transfer assess your town
investment plan against criteria
obviously we have to respond to any
clarifications as required
uh review the in principle case for pro
projects include deliverability and
assurance again any questions on that
and then heads of terms are proposed
with a budget allocated
agreed projects and support from
developer departments and any conditions
are linked to that
and then at that point we'll have a
board meeting to agree
um
gets into business case development
so the board will most likely have to
um conduct another um
tender exercise for a simply qualified
consultant to develop
the work that nexus have done already
and turn that into
from a team
you seem to have lost him i'll give him
a minute to rejoin
so did i disappear then yep
right um i don't know how much of that
he lost
but just talking about viability
alternative source of funding
um and then yeah it's at that point it
moves into the detailed projects and
business cases
and there's ongoing support from the
town's hope
we need to provide you know all the
things i needed for a business case
um and then delivering social value and
and also environmental monitoring impact
analysis
you know the regen digital alt all those
sort of things that you'd expect us to
to have in their business plan
and then we submit those plans those
checks against the
the heads of terms and also the
investment plan
stage criteria and confirm whether we've
met all the conditions that have been
sent upon us and another point and they
agree to final projects and then the
funding is released and at that point we
start we move into delivery phase
which will be the next part of after the
business cases
are agreed is then actual delivery of
the projects hopefully some projects
will be able to be delivered
and sooner than others because obviously
charlotte park
a lot of work and the discussion has
already been
been done and so we'll probably be in
the position to press the button on that
quite quickly
and then some of the other projects may
take a bit longer within the plan to be
delivered
and so what we're going to need to do i
suppose
and what i'm going to suggest is a bring
a paper to the next
board meeting on the 9th of october
is regarding how we start looking at um
the next phase and also thinking about
um that continues that engagement so
some of the things we've been suggesting
is a shadow youth board
and where we try to make sure that
younger people within clay cross are
engaged
so we'd have a shadow board that we
could settle
and hopefully the chair of that that
board would be able to attend this one
to discuss it from their perspective
obviously linking with um chessville
college um
sent to the university if there's any
sort of clay class residents
there who may want to to be involved
or um the the local school
as well because we think that sort of
running under alongside this that'd be
quite
a powerful tool for engagement with
young people and then we can start
thinking about um
you as board members whether in how you
can be
more involved with some working groups
because some of this stuff is going to
deliver
some significant projects and some of
them are obviously directly related to
your
area of work so it's how you can be um
involved in them so i'll start to pull
that together and um
bring that to the next meter just a
rough outline of how we're going to see
that happening
and then if the board agrees that we can
obviously look to implement that
at the appropriate time
okay thank you very much any comments
from the room to that feedback
any questions to call
if not then we can move on to point
eight record of interest
so i'm not sure if this car or damien
yeah sorry
me again uh he'd be sick of society um
so
we've had the audit from mel and their
team on the
plane across boards website there's a
few things that we need to do as a
matter of fact
we've implemented those one of them is
the notes that you've agreed to today
we'll get them on the website
and that's just for the transparency
sake and then there's other parts that
where we meet them
we've met the minimum criteria but you
know best practice is to
you know extend it a bit further so you
should have had an email from
annette chasing you up in terms of uh
board profiles
and if there's any um records of
interest that are outstanding
and the records that interest i think
they're all about that anyway it's just
um
just best practice if we can say you
know this is i'm a member of the board
and this is why i
see the vision for this uh we put a map
on
of the area on the website and a few
other bits that we're
quick wins really but it's just as board
members if you could um
respond to the email from a net if
you've not had an email from a net that
means you've already done it so thank
you for that
and but if you have if you could respond
to that as a matter of religion
that'd be appreciated that's great thank
you very much and finally any other
business
any questions from the board
yes councillor renwick now just to
wrapping up and to say thank you
to all the work that carl and nexus has
done behind the scenes and to you gary
um still very excited about this um
and i think you can say we've got we've
come a long way
and um be interested now to see the the
next bits of detail um to get us over
the line thank you
everybody thank you i think it's been a
really good level of
engagement in today's meeting everyone's
clearly had a good
look at the documents and digested that
so thank you
and again just a reminder to forward any
questions or comments to call directly
by next friday
and if you have no more questions or
comments i'd like to close a meeting
and uh say i look forward to speaking to
you all again in about four weeks time
what was the date again carl was it
friday the
9th october 9th of october perfect
thank you very much have a good weekend
guys
bye everyone thank you
you